hey we're back with your boy Michael
Parsons back on the edge live on bleach
Report app and let's get right into our
game against the Patriots and yes we are
gonna get into the Zack Wilson thing but
I'm always gonna give you the Cowboys
breakdown I know there's a lot going on
about my health hey but I finished that
game y' always know I'm a fight there's
no such thing as going out so I'm G keep
fighting through it I'mma keep rehabbing
and getting ready for this Clash against
the 49ers and we'll get into that in a
little bit um the biggest difference in
this week's performance is that I think
we settled in we said okay we lost
Trayvon um can we still be dominant
without trayon and I think uh we showed
that and that brings me into and I'm
gonna get into him some more but my guy
Don Bland super extremely stepping up he
stepped up for Jay last year and he
stepped up for Trayvon this year a guy
that could go inside or outside and I
mean man I'mma get into more of that a
little bit um but yeah I think we we
said we were just going to dominate
we're going to win up front uh we were
going to win that battle and we're going
to show that we could be dominant um
another lopsided Victory um I wish they
even get three I think uh we're the type
of team that can you know be get we're
the type of team that can hold teams to
to zero points just like we did the uh
the Giants so um we got a big test
coming up this weekend it's gonna be
super exciting um but just know I'mma
always keep fighting for y'all I'm G
always try to stay on that field I don't
even believe in missing practices games
um just because how much it means to me
but your boy gonna get right because we
got a big one this weekend uh my
thoughts on M Jones was I thought Matt
could have played better um it's
definitely not his best game um I think
uh the pass rush and things like that
got to him um a little nervousness a
little little shaky but uh I think he'll
he'll continually get better he's still
is third year in um they still had they
still have yet to have their number one
receiver out there um JuJu's not out
there um so they still growing in a
receiver position need to get help there
um we handed Bill bich his largest loss
of his career um you know that's always
exciting uh everyone know bich is a
Legend um he's dominated the NFL for so
long but he dominated with Tom Brady so
do we say Tom helped it of course Tom
helped it but Bill's still a great coach
uh still dominates on special teams and
things like that so uh we we we're just
going to keep that there Bill's a legend
we have nothing bad to say about Bill uh
but when Bill and Tom were together they
were the best thing going so that's just
what they do
uh but I want to get straight into our
dogs of the week you know my first dog
of the week is going out to my guy donon
Blen holy smokes you know I always pick
on Don about just everything when he Dro
picks and practice and you know just
always trying to get on him a little bit
but man oh man was he the best player
out there on Sunday I mean the plays he
made was just spectacular it was like
you know I feel like you know he really
did that for Trayvon bro because Trayvon
had a pick six uh
against uh M Jones when we went up to
New England uh and things like that but
don don don hey we appreciate you
brother the way to dominate two picks
it's like you you continuously always
getting two picks when you do it uh we
want to see that this weekend too
brother but that is what's up Don keep
going brother and my other dog of the
week my C- dog is khil ma six sacks like
are we serious is that how you're gonna
do the Raiders the Revenge game I know
they bring it up the Revenge game khil
Mack six sacks the coming in tie the
league and sacks like man oh man that
was serious I mean I guess the Raiders
is still turning their sleep for letting
you go I don't I know how anybody lets C
Matt go continually he's an all decade
player has been dominant this league for
so long and he's still dominating
congratulations khil Mack um and then
we're gonna get straight into it uh my
thoughts on Zack Wilson and that game I
thought Zack played his best game Um
Zack D had outplayed Mahomes in the
first qu uh first half um he did fumble
the snap and my it happens to everyone
he no one's perfect um but one thing I
didn't appreciate
was what Rodney Harrison was doing um
you're you're in the NFL right you
there's levels to the NFL there there's
good there's a really good there's Elite
and just God be hon um honestly uh if
I'm being completely honest we knew it
was going to be a battle he's continue
to get better week in and week out and
he's continue to lead week in and week
out but watching that tape man you got
to look at this dude and say oh he is
garbage like we should we should really
tear him apart earlier like I said Zack
Wilson is special man you just got to
give the guy time you know what I mean
wait wait wait wait wait did you say
Zach Wilson is special yeah I think he
had a special night but I don't think
he's special you got to prove that over
you're special cuz you proved it over a
course time he's not special I'm just
saying Chris I'm just
saying
now to me to me bro like that's just not
right and listen I and you know I always
keep my faith in guy and I'm G get and
I'm G just keep this real with you um I
I truly believe that we are not one to
judge we we cannot just keep saying
someone's garbage saying who's special
who's not special now if you're a really
good football player yes Chris Jones is
a really good football player um is he a
better player than Zack Wilson yes but
Chris has built himself upon on that uh
we're not giving that same curtsy of
Zack Wilson let him grow he's continuing
to get better each week and week out and
that's just to me that's a fraudulent
move um because everyone deserves a
chance to be better like I just like
even me I can't I'm not the one to
decide who's special who's not special
you know Zack Wilson is special in his
own way bro like you can't sit here and
say oh you look at the tape and he's
garbage like come on Rodney like you
didn't even do that you can say he's not
a momes tier yeah you can say that but
you can't say that he's not a good
quarterback he's a starting quarterback
in the NFL if Rod you can show me you
could do it then you do it if you were
so good like bro like he's a top five
pick he got drafted that high for a
reason let his traits and everything he
do grow bro Zack bro if you out there I
hope you win I really do I hope you win
I hope you grow into the player that no
one thinks that you can grow into bro
cuz I there's a lot of people that's
hating on you brother uh Hall of Famers
expro players which makes no sense I get
we all love the game of football but at
the end of the day we got to remember
these people are like Zach is a human
being bro Zach is a human we don't use
our platform to degrade other players
that's just not what we do we use our
platform to uplift people we use our
platform to talk good about people say
Zach build confidence you know one every
person in this world just needs someone
to believe in them okay and I'm big on
that uh my person that I grew up that
believed in me was coach ham RP coach
ham that was my dog he was the first
person in my life that told me I could
really be something and I actually
believed in him that he thought I could
be something someone starting with me is
I believe in Zack Wilson I believe that
you can be something special regardless
of what these other guys is saying so if
you out there bro I believe that you can
be special don't ever let someone tell
you can't be special or that you're not
good at something because you're not
good right now uh I'm all about what you
can be not where you're at at right now
you want to beat yourself every year I
want to be a better person next year and
the year after that so that's kind of my
thoughts and we're just going to move on
from that and that should be for all
type
of uh that should be for all guys you
know all platforms let's build these
guys and say hey you need to get better
it's not our job and uh our job to
degrade people and put people down we're
just being you guys are just being
social media bullies social media
bullies no one in life likes a bully bro
um and I'm tired of seeing these guy
bulli these athletes and do all this
stuff bro like let's not bully these
people no more I'm I'm so sick of seeing
bullies I hate bullies like this is is
some clown stuff clown Behavior we're
not on this app to and we're not using
our platform to clown and Bully other
athletes bro that's just not what we're
doing and we need to stop this that's
not who we are bro this is this is
so-called be a Brotherhood whether
you're a elite or not cuz the same guy
Rodney Harrison was the type of guy that
come and shake my hand and tell me type
of fine player I am and we try to Hype
me up into my face but don't do that for
another athlete who may not be on the
same tiar and put him down bro cuz
that's not right and I don't think no
one should do that talking about Chris
you're special he's not special you're
not the one to decide who's special and
who's not special Ronnie I'm sorry yes
you was a good player but that's not
your job and is not what you should be
doing and I'm tired of the social media
bullies and I'mma just move on from it
because it it it truly makes me upset
bro it truly makes me so Zack keep
winning and uh we believe in you from
this side and and I'mma just put like
that bro um and yo now we going to get
into dolphin
bills uh what my first thoughts was I
was truly surprised uh I thought it
would be a closer game but what I've
always told people is if Josh Allen is
on he is a hard player to beat I don't
care who you are who you going against
if Josh Allen decides hey I'm not going
to turn the ball over and I'm going go
out here and throw and I'mma run and do
what I do um my gosh Josh I mean come on
y'all like Josh is that guy um that's
why I had up they were both in my top
four of top four AFC teams you saw a top
four Clash and they found a way to slow
down Tyreek Hill uh the rush got after
him and mind you they still don't have
Von Miller so this is gonna be really ex
exciting matchup uh that we're seeing
this division is intense right now um
they handed the Miami Dolphins their
first loss of the season so it's it's
good intent over there um we we should
all be getting excited for this stuff
and one thing that I liked about this
game was stefhon dig Stone Cold Steve
Austin if you a WWE fan and you didn't
like this s this was I this might be top
five s's of all time bro like this was
hard I like I'm thinking about stealing
this uh for myself bro like I might have
to steal if I get an Endzone I need to
find me some beers and Clash them too
like this was real uh this that was a
fun message that was a true uh Sunday
football game I was watching it before
my game and that was intense game I was
I was actually shocked I thought it
would be a way closer game um but you
know it is what it is that that's just
Josh Allen he's special bro and that's
why he'll stay in my top four I mean he
just played this game and when you get
your best receiver to go up with you I
mean their their Duo is pretty
Unstoppable so uh it it was fun to watch
it was was really fun and watch and
we're going to get into a a a you know
an elite AFC team that's kind of
struggling right now uh and that's the
Bengals we're now we're saying what's
going on with the Bengals you know this
isn't how no one thought uh the Bengals
would start uh I don't think anyone
thought the Bengals would start like
this it's a little
confusing uh you know it's starting to
get to that point like does there need
to be a switch or there need to be a
change
um what's going on right let's listen to
Jamar chase after the Bengals lost to
the Titans
okay I'm open I'm always [__] open
excuse my profan I'm sorry I'm open I'm
always [__] open excuse my you know
what this is this is this is Rage okay
um yes I do believe Jamar is always open
if Jamar is single high I'm giving them
a chance um and there needs if he find
ways but you kind of hate to see this
because when you know Joe burrow and
Jamar they're the they're the tandem
okay one and two all right you got T
Higgins who's uh one and that's like the
guy he likes to throw to if jamar's not
open and things like that but I hate to
see that just because of how close they
are you know and that kind of
builds a
little it just builds a little bit of
bad taste between uh qb1 and wide
receiver one and you kind of hate to see
that like you don't want want to see the
social media side of all this like this
and that you don't want to see that uh
so I hope that gets cleaned up the
Bengals the NFL is better when the
Bengals are better and especially the
talent that they have it's a little
uh it's confusing because they're so
good and they kind of have to do it
right now after you give burrow that
contract and you gotta Think About You
Gotta Give T Higgins one soon and You
Gotta Give Jamar Chase one soon it's
like will they be able to keep all those
pieces together um and that's going the
tough part so you hope the Bengals will
turn on now because of the people they
have to pay uh starting next year so
it's going to be pretty interesting to
see how things go but this needs to turn
around fast uh starting you know one and
three is pretty tough especially in the
NFL to bounce back but if anyone can do
it the Bengals can because if we
remember uh jamar's rookie year they
started off losing and they came back
and went all the way to the Super Bowl
so it's not something you haven't done
before four but it's something that's
going to be harder because people have
they have film on them now they have uh
routines they have everything on them
now they're saying hey this is how we
could beat the Bengals so they have to
switch it up offensively have to think
get things going ASAP and no you do not
sit Joe burrow you make him tough this
out you make them fight through
adversity uh I've never seen a champion
and haven't been battle tested when
you're a battle test that makes true
Champions like I said last week uh when
we lost
for uh Cardinals we got battle tested uh
we got we got outclass and we got to
make sure that doesn't happen again okay
um and that leads to Derrick Henry
having his first 100 yard game of the
season um where do we rank D Derrick
Henry I think we have to rank Derrick
Henry uh top five easily uh this guy's
always been a elite back since he came
in the league uh pretty much Unstoppable
pretty much a horse like this guy he
stiff arms people he trucks people he's
constantly falling forward uh Derrick
Henry uh I'm glad they did not do you
wrong like the rest of these running
backs keep going brother keep shining
keep doing you keep putting on for the
running back class um because you the
rest of your brothers got to get
back commanders Eagles uh that was a
hell of a game I I honestly you would
think that the Eagles uh I thought they
were have dominated a little bit more
you've seen great games out of AJ Brown
uh AJ Brown and Jaylen HZ seemed like
they're finding each other again um but
the biggest thing everyone wants to talk
about is the tush push uh what do I
think about the tush push and let's take
a look at
it I honestly just think they have the
team to do the touch push uh we stopped
the England when they try to do the same
thing to us um it's all about who you
have the Eagles have the best o line in
a game so yes it's a cheat code uh
they're Unstoppable at it they have the
bestto line and they have uh a
quarterback who's squatting 600 and he
knows how to move his legs and push
forward so yes it's OD like it's it
should be and it's hard to say oh it's
illegal for one team because who they
have we just have to deal with it we
have to adjust we have to prepare to
stop it and and it's not up to the
league to say hey just because you can't
stop it we have to take it away no we
have to get better we have to get
stronger up front and we have to stop it
we have to get them out of it uh you
know I don't want nothing uh to say Hey
you know that that's kind of like
suckers like I don't want to be a part
of a league that's like hey I can't stop
something I'm not strong enough I'm not
good enough to beat it so we got to take
it out the game no guys this is this is
football this is man football we got to
man up and stop it um and that's just
what it is uh will we be able to stop it
it's going to be a good one and we're
GNA find out uh pretty soon um I can't
wait to to see it's going to be a clash
um of course Eagles Cowboys biggest Riv
in football um y'all know it's going to
be it's going to go down to the wire and
uh I'm not gonna put too much too many
words on it but it's gonna be a good
game and it's going to be some things
that we got to stop we have to get and
uh it that's all has to be said uh some
rookies that are surprised in the league
that no one's talking about is CJ St and
I know people are hyp getting into the
bejon hyp train will'll get that but we
need to jump on board with CJ stra um
the most pass attempts without
interceptions to start your career and I
want y to realize who uh CJ stra has now
beat okay and he just did something
Deshawn Watson hasn't been able to do
um he just he just dominated the Ste the
Steelers defense a defense that we said
had TJ wat has Cameron Hayward has Alex
seith uh Minka and he dominated them I
mean CJ St is the real deal and not only
did he do that he just beat the Jaguars
who I think the Jaguars have a top 10
defense with guys like Andre Cisco they
got guys like Josh Allen who just had
another threet game they got guys like
Ulan they got guys like uh they have a
lot of guys that are really good uh and
we're just we're we cannot let CJ going
ONN he was my he was my qb1 coming out
of the draft I don't know who um I don't
know if y'all remember I was like man
CJ's that guy I think he's going to be
dominant and things like that because
his confidence the things that he's
bringing to this game I think CJ is
gonna be the offensive rookie of the
year uh if it's not beon it's gonna come
down to the wire but he stays on his
Pace I think CJ walks away with it uh
it's gonna be a tense battle between
bjon and CJ but man oh man CJ is looking
really good he got two wins in a row he
won the first home game in Houston since
2021 so uh we need to give it up for uh
CJ I mean this is this is the real deal
I think CJ's the real deal uh and we
also need to talk about my other
offensive guy who coming into the light
is NOA uh I think Shawn McVey always
does a really good job of giving his
receiver one the ball and finding ways
to uh get him open and I mean he's just
a prim example he fit into this Cooper
cup roll and I can't wait to see him see
what he does when Cooper Cup come back
now soon people are going to focus on
him but when Cooper cup comes back
Cooper cup is not someone you just don't
slant the field to okay this this Duo
right here is going to be some serious
work and it's gonna be extremely fun to
see uh Matthew Stafford still looking
good it's it's going to be impressive
weekend it was a hell of a comeback um
by the Rams and they're looking really
good so it those are three players we
really need to talk about right now and
that's CJ stra bean and Nico right now
and it's looking extremely well um beon
oh my God anyone see Bean's Juke did
anyone see see that oh my goodness I
mean I don't even think we have it up
here but bejan's juking what he's been
able to do in this league has been
really Dynamic I think that's why you
take running backs top 10 he is defining
this league of why you should take him
and we would love to see Jamir Gibbs get
going a little bit more I know they got
him in like this backup roll I would
love to see uh
beon coming uh jir Gibbs coming to the
road that bejan is right now and that's
get him more cares get him going because
I think them two young backs can really
be dynamic and take over this league and
it's a uh jir is going to be someone
that we see pretty heavy but it's going
to be it's going to be look at this oh
my God oh my like that is just
ridiculous Bean is so Walky I mean he's
a Do-it all back he really reminds me of
Squan Barkley like when saquon was doing
his rookie year we seen that at a bejan
these top uh 10 running backs that we
see coming into this league that's what
we're seeing right now and uh it's
really exciting exciting to see uh and
you know these got this this Trio
ceiling right now uh I think these are
going to be Pro Bowl players I think
bejon Goes Pro Bowl this year I think
that you know CJ keeps playing the way
he is and he you know I think CJ might
be a pro bowl uh quarterback this year
he's a pro bowl caliber quarterback
without a true dynamic number one that
Tua has you know uh Josh Allen has
Stefon Diggs you know
uh uh Patrick Mahomes has Travis Kelce
Travis Kel is almost a receiver however
you say it uh Joe burrow has uh Jamar
Chase anti Higgins we're
seeing CJ shroud do this with tank Dow
Nico Collins and Brevin Jordan not
saying they're really good players but
they're not players who uh stamp their
yourself in this league like the rest of
these guys so this is something we
really need to take notice of and CJ
strad is hooping and he needs more
credit uh than people are giving right
now um and that just moves us on to the
Broncos
Bears if the season ended right now the
Bears will have pick one and two now how
scary was that now everyone knows I'm a
huge Justin Fields guy I'm not saying
the Bears should uh get rid of Justin
Fields because Justin Fields just played
his best game of football last week and
his defense let him down but the
question is what do you do at pick one
and two if the season ended right now do
you take Caleb Williams who I think
might be the best quarterback recruit to
ever come into the NFL the way he's
dominating I think at one point that
game last week against USC he had six
incompletions but had six touchdowns
like what do you do when you got a guy
like that and then you have pick number
one and then you could possibly say oh
my gosh we could get Marvin Harrison but
Justin Fields is an elite quarterback
and he showed that last week the Bears
have a lot to think about especially if
they don't pick it up where do you guys
want to go with this season uh do you
tank and get another number one receiver
especially because you're not getting
what you thought you were going to get
out of Chase clay poool and there's been
a lot of drama with that um that's
that's something that we have to think
about what do the Bears do if the season
ends right now um and where do they
think they're going forward do you move
on with Caleb Williams and do you get
Marvin Harrison do you get someone to
add to their defense because that's
someone they desperately need
desperately need I can't believe they
let Jaylen Carter get away from him I
definitely think he would have made a
huge difference on this Chicago defense
you see how much he's dominating and the
Eagles in her system so uh that's
something neat but the real praise not
only is it Justin fields and the bears
but uh we need to talk about Shawn
Payton's 21-point comeback for the the
uh Broncos comeback okay now let's talk
about this
right I want to talk about how sea cut
his sleeves off first is now is this
some type of superstition or something
that he's doing um this was this was
like almost like you know how some
people like all I gotta roll up my
sleeves like I got to get intense like
it is it like I don't know if that was
like his moment like let me roll up my
sleeve let me stop playing with these
boys like we better than them that's
what I just saw Shawn pton just showed
that dog at him like that was that was a
dog Moment Like and they then they came
back they scored 24 straight uh come
back from a 21o deficit which was
serious that was serious bro
um I think the Broncos have a chance to
turn the season around after coming back
now they're saying hey we can get stops
we can do this uh their defense had
stepped up in that second half uh
everything turned around for them uh I
would love to see Rush keep playing the
way he's been playing Rush played a
great game last week just with Justin
Fields I think both that was both of
their best games in the season but I
would love to see the Broncos turn
around because this was a top tier
defense last year and it was like last
year it was like the defense is so good
now the but the offense isn't helping
now it's kind of the opposite where the
offense is doing real good and the
defense are struggling so you love to
see both sides click a little bit more
uh so and get that intensity you guys
got like Pastor Tain Randy Gregory uh
you get you did well in the free agency
so I would love to see these guys turn
around a little bit more um and and
things like
that now I now y'all see the jerseys on
my wall right now right you see Herbert
you see Garner and you see Giannis okay
I put my Giannis up there right now
because of Damen Lillard trade and y'all
know how I feel about my my boy Giannis
now Dame time Dame time is back oh man
oh man Giannis Dame time and it kept
Middleton now this is a serious Trio
this should not be slept on this Eastern
Conference side it used to be very
lopsided West Coast uhuh this east side
is serious you add Dame time I I mean to
be fair the Bucks finish number one
without Dame Time Imagine what they do
with him uh and they're going to spread
the four and it's going to help Giannis
get more buckets this is going to be a
fun match up to see uh with them
together y know I'm GNA go up to
Milwaukee and watch a game because Dame
doll is up there with my boy Giannis
it's gonna be super fun to see uh and I
felt a little bad because my man sawce
got that weak late holding call yes that
is suspicious but we're not going to get
into that right now because I still need
my calls this season I don't want to
call out them refs because we know what
happened up there in New York but that
very suspicious uh and it y'all know
what I'm trying to say here um but yeah
and herbo Y know he's a beast and they
got that win over the Raiders this week
so that was a big DB for them uh who
would be Damon Lillard in the
NFL huh this is this is kind of tough
like cause Dam got that rapping
swag
um who
who would y'all say that Damen Lillard
uh who is Damen Lillard of the
NFL who we put him there like C you know
he got that Charisma he got that rap he
got that juice I might say maybe like
Stefan Diggs maybe y' y'all think like
Stefon Diggs maybe like C he's also a
little quiet I think I think I might go
Stefan Diggs maybe um that that' be fun
um all right and I saved The Best For
Last and that's the 49ers y'all know
what type of game this is this is a
playoff uh contention um this is a huge
game huge uh not it's a NFC matchup
y'all know it's gonna come down to the
wire um it's gonna be a very good game
um
and I already told y'all Brock pie is
the real deal I
mean Brock py has dominated he has not
lost a regular season game yet we have
our
handful um yall know who they have they
have Christian mcaffry who just went an
absurd last week LeBron even shouted
this man out when you get a shout out
from LeBron LeBron's random tweets you
know you are hooping I mean this is I
mean look at what Christian mcaffrey did
against the uh Arizona Cardinals four
touchdowns I mean bro I mean Christian
mcaffry is the best back in the NFL he
can do everything he's in the pass he's
in the run uh it's going to be extreme
matchup and you see IU they got Debo
they got Trent Williams and Brock per
keeps proving himself week and week out
dominating doing what he do um the
question is will we hand uh Brock py his
first loss of the season that's
something we don't know that's why we
let the pass talk we let football talk
for us and it goes things like that this
is gonna be a very good game and
especially it's at the place where we
lost at um I think it's going to be
defensive game as always we got to come
come in there find a way to make uh pry
onedimensional and be dominant but you
know I think he's a good quarterback uh
it's gonna be super fun to watch and I
need every Cowboys Nation I need y'all
to pull up to the Bay we need to make
this a home game I'm calling Cowboys
Nation out to step up and be with us in
the bay we need every single one of
y'all we need to go up another notch we
need to be the best baby we need Cowboys
Nation there I need all of y'all there
we're goingon to need all hands AB board
to knock this team out um and that's
just what it's going to take and let's
get straight to it and uh to finish off
my segment I want to take some final
questions from the chat and you know
let's just get some questions from the
chat uh one question is what's up
warriors uh with the Warriors hat before
you play with in the Bay Area um those
of yall know I'm a huge Stephen Curry
fan Splash Bros um I won four titles
with them so that's just where I'm at
with that yall know I'm I'm with the
Warriors but now I'm in D am with the I
am with the Mavs a little bit but just
know I like to rep my Warriors a little
bit here and there um because you know
this Splash Bros you know Stephen Curry
changed a game of basketball and uh
that's just my guy that's just someone
who I always root for um what on your
thought of us being three and a three
and a half underdogs uh that's that's
just what it is they're underfeed team
um it just is what it is like you know
they deserve it we lost to the cardinal
they beat the Cardinals it just is what
it is we got to come out and uh show
that we're the best
um how is my ankle uh my ankle is very
well you know I I gotta get treatment I
gotta you know keep it going uh I gotta
get my rehab I gotta get ready because I
gotta go against the best tackle in
football and that's Trent Williams uh
and it's always gonna be a fun match I
actually have his jersey he's going up
on the wall next week so uh you know
this is gonna be a fun game I can't wait
to get out there got to get back at it I
got to get back into my rehab and
treatment right after this uh do you
think Joe Burrow's injury or is it
something mental um I think it's a
combination of both uh I remember when
Dak was coming back from his like injury
and his hand injury it took him a little
bit to get back into it um you as much
treatment and things like that you know
you gotta put trust back into your legs
you gotta put trust back into everything
that uh that you've been training for
and it's hard when things is aching and
things feel a little wobbly maybe Joe
burrow don't feel confident in his leg
yet where it's prohibiting to do things
that we seen Joe burrow do and that's
just make magical plays um that you know
is restricting him so we just got to be
careful watch how they go and hopefully
they turn it around um do you think
Jamal was throwing Burl under the bus no
I don't think Jamal was turning him
under the bus he just laying his
quarterback he's open I think we've seen
that with AJ Brown and Jen Herz on the
sideline uh when you're being
competitive and you're bringing uh
you're doing all this um especially in
the National Football League it just
seems to bring the best out of people I
think that's something that Jamar wish
he could take back uh I don't
necessarily think he was taking a shot
at Joe he's just like you know I just
think it's frustration you know when
you're frustrated and things aren't
going the way that you want them to go
it just brings some type of frustration
and there's nothing wrong with that um
so Joe B and Jamar are just fine they're
brothers in real life I seen it with my
own two eyes and they're both great
people so is nothing to uh uh think
about uh posi with it
and uh they said I have uh 10 uh you I
have a career as a commentator in 101 15
years after the NFL uh truly appreciate
that you know this is something that I
love to do I think is my way of speaking
about football I love the game of
football I love what it bring uh and I
believe in just storytelling football is
a storytelling sport I love documenting
I love watching it um and it's just our
chance to storytelling this show is me
storytelling you what's going around the
league the truth the ends and out I'mma
keep it real about the players I'mma
keep who's struggling who's not
struggling what's behind it because it's
not always what you see on TV it's not
always you know things always go in the
background and you know people just like
to throw out absurd things about players
and accusations and things because they
want to give you clickbait this show is
to give you the real deal spill about
what's going on in the league the truth
not downplaying nobody I don't want no
clickbait I want y'all in here because
y'all gonna get the real scoop about
what's going in uh what's going on in
NFL and if there's something that y'all
want me to talk about y'all want me to
bring up yall know just tune into the
chat I'll bring it up for you uh and ask
these questions or even at me on all my
social medias my Twitter's Instagram
whatever I'll bring it up I'll bring you
the real sco what's going on this the
real deal on the edge I appreciate
everyone for tuning in I love you guys I
appreciate you guys for tuning in
listening and hear me speak and that's
it on the edge that's your boy Michael
Parsons I see cow I see you Cowboy
nation in the bay we need you it's going
down top three NFC matchup it's going
down baby I see you on the bay your boys
out
[Music]
peace